well this week marked two years since
minneapolis police officer greg sherman
handcuffed george floyd pinned him face
down on the street and fatally choked
him sparking a global reckoning on race
and policing the world of sport was at
the forefront of that reckoning taking
the knee inspired by colin kaepernick's
race protest in america became a global
sporting gesture but two years on is
taking renee still having the same
impact well joining me now is michael
holding one of the greatest triggers of
all time who says if you don't kneel i
know where you stand michael fantastic
to speak to you thank you for joining
the show
thanks for having me pierce glad to be
with you i read your book a few months
ago and i i sent a note to you by your
agent just saying how incredibly moved i
was by the book it is without a doubt
the most powerful book about racism
and hopeful in many ways i think i've
ever read and i don't say that lightly
and at the forefront of it is why we
kneel how we rise and i think my
question for you right now as we get to
a stage where in football
certain teams now in the premier league
have begun not to take the knee certain
black players wilfred zahara crystal
palace and so on have decided that
they're not going to do anymore because
i think it's become ineffective this
debate about whether sporting teams
should continue to do it and whether
it's still effective is now beginning to
to be had what is your view
pierce i as far as i'm concerned taking
a knee should not be a ticking the box
exercise
if you believe
in what you are talking about about the
racism and trying to change what's
happening and trying to make the world a
better world
taking a knee is a gesture that has been
accepted around the world
as
yes
i believe this i am joining with you i
support you
so i'm signaling to you and everyone
else that i
am with you
that's what i see taking in the eyes now
it is obvious that a lot of people do
not believe that taking the knee has had
any impact at all because yes you don't
want to be just taking a knee and
nothing else happens what's the point of
taking the knee if nothing happens but
taking the knee should not then say to
you well nothing is happening i can't
stop taking the knee because if you stop
taking the knee that is signaling to
everyone i'm satisfied with what is
going on everything has changed i'm
happy now i don't longer need to take a
knee it is a prerequisite pierce to
action right that is what i look at
taking in years you know when i go and
watch arsenal my football team i'm
always struck by 60 000 people all
applaud all of them there's never a
single boo when the players many of whom
are black in the arsenal team take the
knee there's a lot of respect now for it
whereas at the start there was quite a
lot of animosity at certain clubs now i
feel it's become part of
football and i like that you know and i
think it is an important part here's my
other question for you though
you've had a player at paris
saint-germain
it wasn't about taking the knee but it
was about whether he should wear the
lgbt colors for for psg when they played
a game he's from senegal and he decided
he didn't want to do that and didn't
play
should players whether it's taking the
knee against racism whether it's an lgbt
uh protest whatever it may be should any
players for any kind of sport be
compelled
to do it or what is your view
no i don't believe anyone should be
compelled to do anything like that
pierce you you support it wholeheartedly
or not nobody should be compelling
people to support any cards if you do
not believe in it you don't support it
that is my belief i just want to see
people acknowledging that things are not
right whatever the issue is you either
acknowledge it and you say yes things
are not right and i'm going to support
whatever you are doing or you say it to
yourself no i don't believe that what
you're supporting is right i'm not going
to support whatever you are supporting
it's as simple as that i don't see how
you can dictate to anyone and say you
have to take the knee right or you have
to wear this shirt or you have to i
don't believe in that i don't believe in
forcing people to be supporting things
that don't believe it no i agree and i
think i think i think it has the
opposite effect if you do that
just finally michael do you feel two
years on from what happened to george
floyd that the aftermath of that was so
gigantic around the world there was a
real movement wasn't there rising up
against what had happened but do you
feel there's been substantive progress
now in the battle against racial
injustice since then
i definitely believe that i've seen
enough for me to believe peers that
there has been action and people have
no a way to the situation
a lot of people have been going through
their lives
they have been comfortable nothing has
affected them as far as we've seen this
concern and they have just drifted along
they've just floated on the tide a lot
of people have not realized that
something is wrong and they are willing
to join the fight i have had too much
positive feedback from this book that
i've written about too much positive
feedback from what other people have
said and done for me to not recognize
that people are coming to see that
there's a problem and people are willing
to work towards solving this problem you
see a lot of people used to walk around
peers and say oh i'm not racist i don't
have a problem i don't have to support
anything i know what i am but the times
of just being not racist are over you
have no god to be anti-racist you have
got to show people that those who are
racist braces are wrong and you're going
to tell them that they're wrong so that
people recognize that yes it's not the
way to go
michael uh you brought me enormous
pleasure as a cricketer one of the
greatest fast bowlers ever lived uh
you've brought me a lot of thought uh
constructive thought with this book it's
a magnificent book i urge everyone to
read it why we kneel how we rise i think
you're a force for such good in this
debate because you come at it from a
place of love and you just want people
to understand what it's about this book
made me really understand it in a way
that no other book has done so thank you
for writing it and keep going because
we're all right behind you
thank you very much pierce i hope the
book does what i'm trying to do
to get everyone all races all priests to
understand that we are all human beings
and the world is a much better place if
we are all together we are all humans
just let us all get together and make
the world a better place absolutely
michael great to talk to you thank you
so much for joining me